do you remember those leaked videos of
Nintendo switch consoles that appeared
online early last week
well Nintendo and law-enforcement have
gotten to the bottom of how several
people got their hands on Nintendo
switch consoles weeks before launch
Nintendo told IGN in a statement earlier
this week individuals claimed to
prematurely purchase a small number of
Nintendo switch systems from an
unspecified retailer Nintendo has
determined these units were stolen in an
isolated incident by employees of a u.s.
distributor with one system being
illegally resold the individuals
involved have been identified terminated
from their place of employment and out
under investigation by local law
enforcement authorities on criminal
charges was it really worth it gang but
it seems the neogaf user who posted the
first videos online may be an innocent
party in this whole affair hip hop the
robot who you may remember for having a
seriously enviable handle and posting a
short video of the switches startup and
system screens has shared some more
details on his involvement on NeoGAF the
barista by day unreleased video game
detail leaker by night said for the sake
of clarification I will say that I don't
think the person I got it from knew and
therefore I certainly didn't know but
somewhere down the chain some switches
had mysteriously disappeared so while it
was unknown to me once I found out that
it had probably been stolen I didn't
feel comfortable keeping it hip hop the
robot has since returned to the console
to Nintendo the Nintendo switch is on
track to launch in just under two weeks
on March 3 for more video game crime
updates be sure to subscribe to GameSpot
on YouTube and for all the Nintendo
Switch coverage you'll need don't switch
away from games bud
you